JUSTIN BOYAN: Hi.
I'm Justin, a product
manager in Google Search.
In the next few
minutes, I'll show you
an easy way for event
organizers, performers, venues,
and ticket sellers to promote
their events in Google Search
through the Knowledge Graph.
The Knowledge Graph
is Google's system
for organizing
information about millions
of well known people, places,
and things in the real world.
The better we
understand these things,
the better we can understand
what web pages are really
talking about, and what users
are really searching for.
The information in
the Knowledge Graph
comes from lots of
sources, like Wikipedia,
Google Maps, the
FDA for drug data,
Music Brains for
album data, and so on.
But in the case of
events, we think
the best source of
event information
is the event
organizers themselves.
For example, when people ask
about Keith Urban's upcoming
concert dates, we'd like to give
them an authoritative answer
from Keith himself or
from his official website.
Likewise, when people
search for what's
going on at a local
venue-- whether that's
a music club, a stadium, a
theater, or the local library--
we think that venue's website
is the best source of answers.
So that's the basis
for our new approach
to events in Google Search.
We're asking event organizers to
take charge of their own events
in the Knowledge Graph by
adding structured data markup
to their official websites.
Google can then read this
markup as it crawls the web,
add it to the knowledge graph,
and show it to users in search.
So I'm going to
show you how easy it
is to add that markup thanks
to the new JSON-LD format.
But before I get to
the technical details,
let's take a quick peek at one
way events from the knowledge
graphs show up in search.
We'll start with a song
someone told me about.
It's called "Alligator Strut."
All right.
Going to Google that song.
And I learn it's
by Anton Schwartz.
Hmm, who's he?
All right, he's a saxophonist.
He's got a few albums out.
He's well educated.
And he's got upcoming events.
Let's take a look at those.
All right, here's a
nice rich list of events
that I can swipe through.
I can discover one near me.
When I click on it, I get
more details, including a map.
And I get the ability
to click right
through to his
official website, where
I can get all the details.
Let's learn about this event.
Right on, with the
Boston Symphony.
I'm getting a ticket.
[MUSIC - ANTON SCHWARTZ,
"ALLIGATOR STRUT"]
All right.
And that's just one example of
how the Knowledge Graph helps
people discover events.
In addition, the
Knowledge Graph powers
event rich snippets
in search results.
It powers event
listings in Google Maps.
And it powers
notifications in Google Now
to automatically inform people
of interesting nearby events
and when their favorite
bands are coming to town.
So again, to be eligible
for all these cool features,
event organizers have to
markup their websites.
We pay special attention to
data on the official websites
of touring performers-- like
musical artists and comedians--
to venues official
websites, and soon
to the official websites of
annual events like festivals
and conferences.
Finally, for any event
where tickets are sold,
we'll also look to the
primary ticketers official
website for ticketing details.
So a request for markup on all
these websites is the same.
Use the schema.org
vocabulary to label
the key properties
of each event.
Schema.org is just a set
of standard property names
for structured data agreed upon
by the major search engines.
When Google
processes a web page,
it can recognize
schmea.org properties
in several different
markup formats,
including microdata and RDFa.
However, in this talk,
I'm going to tell you
about a new format, JSON-LD.
Unlike the other
formats, JSON-LD
doesn't require you to
interweave your structured data
with the HTML displayed content.
That makes it the most
developer friendly format yet,
and Google is embracing it.
All right, let's
take a closer look.
Here's what JSON looks like
when embedded in a web page,
in this case Keith
Urban's tour page.
As you can see, it's just
a block of JSON data.
The JSON keys highlighted
in yellow, like start date
and location, are
schema.org property names.
The whole JSON block should
be wrapped in a script tag.
And then you can insert
anywhere in the web page,
either the head or the body.
OK, let's go through some of
the interesting properties here.
First, the @type.
You should use the most
specific subtype of event
that applies to your event.
Popular subtypes include comedy
event, festival, food event,
music event, theater
event, and sports event.
This helps search engines
categorize your event,
and in some cases
lets you specify
extra fields relevant to that
type of event such as home team
and away team on a sports event.
Next, the start date.
This needs to be
in ISO 8601 format.
The time is included
in the field.
And it's assumed to
be in the local time
zone of the event location.
If the event has a
definite ending time,
you can specify that using a
separate end date property.
Next, location.
The value of this property
is a nested sub-object
of type place.
In our experience, this type
of hierarchical data nesting
was really easy for
developers to mess up
in the microdata RDFa format.
But in JSON-LD,
it's very natural.
You can see that the
place sub-object should
have a name property, that's
the name of the venue,
and an address property.
The address can be given as
a single string, which Google
is good at picking apart, or
as a set of individual fields
in another nested sub-object
of type postal address.
There's another interesting
property on the place here.
Same as fiddlersgreenamp.com.
This property is
designed to help
you connect your data
to the Knowledge Graph.
The value of the
same as property
should be a URL
that unambiguously
indicates the items identity.
For example, the venue's
Wikipedia page, Freebase page,
or official homepage.
In this case, the
homepage of Fiddler's
Green Amphitheater
the theaters provided
which helps Google understand
that Fiddler's Green refers
to the amphitheater
in Colorado, not
to the mythical location in the
afterlife where fiddlers fiddle
and dancers dance
for all eternity.
So, moving back to the code.
We're up to the event's
performer markup.
Again, note the same
as link, this time
to a Wikipedia page ensuring
that Google can understand
exactly which real world artist
is performing at the event.
The same as URLs,
by the way, don't
have to appear in the user
visible portion of the web
page.
They're only a hint
to search engines
about how to understand
the user visible text.
If there are multiple
performers at the event, great.
Use the JSON array
to list all of them.
Finally, the last key
property is offers.
This is where
ticketing information
goes within an offer sub-object.
For a ticketed event, the
key property to specify
is the URL of the web
page the user should
visit to purchase a
ticket to the event.
If you specify a ticket link,
then behind the scenes Google
will also visit that
web page and try
to gather more ticketing
details from whatever
structured markup we find there.
So let's look at what we might
find on the ticketers web page.
The rest of the markup
should basically be the same,
but on the ticket
offer, we should
expect some extra properties.
The category of ticket, such
as primary or secondary,
the price of admission,
the availability status,
which should be set to sold
out if the event is sold out,
and the valid from
date, which specifies
when these tickets go on sale.
So that's how you markup
an event using JSON-LD.
Are you done?
Just one step left that every
developer knows-- testing.
To make sure your
markup is correct
before you deploy it
on the web, copy it
into Google's newly updated
Event Markup Tester.
It provides detailed
error messages
on both syntax problems, like
a missing comma, and data
problems, like a missing
required property
or wrongly formatted date.
You can also see a
summary of all the markup
we've found on your website in
the Structured Data Dashboard.
That's available
in Webmaster Tools.
And that's all there is to it.
When Google next
crawls your site,
we'll read the marked up
events to verify that they're
consistent with what
users see on the web page
and then import them
directly into the Knowledge
Graph for use across
Google products.
For more examples
and documentation,
please visit our help page
at g.co/strutureddata.
And after you've got
the markup deployed--
[MUSIC - ANTON SCHWARTZ,
"ALLIGATOR STRUT"]
Why not celebrate with
a night out on the town?
Thank you.